- Hi everyone, good afternoon.
I am utterly delighted to invite you all
to the follow-up discussion
session and conversation
from yesterday's excellent presentation
by Dr. Sarah Teichmann.
On inference, the nature of inference,
and rather, The Inference of Nature
Cause and Effect in Molecular Biology.
And we are delighted to
have as a conversance today,
professor Neil Lawrence, who
is the DeepMind professor
of Machine Learning at the
University of Cambridge.
Professor Lawrence is the
inaugural DeepMind professor
at the University of Cambridge,
He has been working on
machine learning models
for over 20 years.
He recently returned to
Academia after three years
as the director of
machine learning at Amazon
and his main interest has
been in the interaction
of machine learning
with the physical world.
And this interest of his was triggered by
the deploying of machine
learning in the African context,
which I'm quite curious to
hear more about from him
when end to end solutions
are normally required
and he has inspired his work,
has inspired many new
directions, research directions
at the interface of machine
learning and systems research
and a lot of his work is funded
with an AI fellowship from
the Alan Turing Institute.
He is also very well
vetted, has many awards
and recognition.
And I won't dwell on
those because I'm dying
to get into conversation and
participate in the discussion
that he and professor
Teichmann are going to have.
So Neil, Sarah, absolutely delighted
to have you both here this afternoon
and I'm looking forward to a
smooth intellectually choppy,
but a hopefully a smooth
presentation this evening.
Thank you both.
- Thanks so much Priya and
thanks very much for the
invite to be the conversant and for Sarah
also for great presentation yesterday.
So I'm gonna open with a
sort of a short discussion.
I won't use slides,
but I wanted to riff off the
opening to one of the questions
which was William Kwok said
before he phrased this question,
he said, I'm not a real
scientist, I'm a social scientist.
And I kind of think that that's,
there's a problem at the heart
of what he's saying there.
Because we're in a world where
there's many, many complex things
we'd like to understand
and make decisions on.
And yet some of them apparently
fall beyond the remit
of what science is capable of
answering because effectively
it's not William, that's letting us down,
it's science, that's letting William down
if he feels that to be the case.
And I think what's so exciting
about Sarah's presentation
yesterday and what we're seeing
in the sort of the shift
in biology to a much more,
I mean, it's always had
quantitative elements,
but the dominance of quantitative work
in terms of scientific discovery,
I think it has to be our hope
that the same type of shift will occur
with a sort of move towards computational
and quantitative social science.
And that's not, by the way,
as I hope I'll highlight,
as I discussed to sort of
diminish qualitative research,
I think that's absolutely vital.
But I thought that was a sort
of interesting starting point
because what's really going on
and what we saw a lot with
what Sarah talked about
is the complexity of systems
we're trying to be scientific about.
And if you think Sarah sort of ended
talking about immune system,
I mean, it's one of my
favorite refs to sort of say,
what do you think we now
understand the brain?
You should hear what we don't
know about the immune system.
And the immune system is
sort of widespread across
the all animal kingdoms
and anticipated extraordinary
type of intelligence,
but not just the complexity
of those systems,
but also the answer of,
well, if we're talking about
inference about the systems,
what is knowledge itself?
So what does it mean to
understand those things?
And I think that that
also came through a lot
in what Sarah was saying.
And I think particularly
you sit in biological work.
So part of what that means is perhaps
to be able to predict what might happen
in the case of an
intervention in that system.
And you see that a lot
in biological models,
but Sarah actually used a
number of different ways
of trying to explain how
these systems operate.
And the first couple she used
was what I would talk about
is dimensionality reduction
and giving you a map
as she would call that.
And it's so interesting
and it goes all the way back to Gauss
with mapping technologies
and Gauss was actually doing
it for mapping the earth.
But what we're often trying to do
is build a map, which means
that the sort of functional approximation
from a low dimensional space
to a high dimensional space in
which we collected the data.
And it's interesting
the extent we use that
analogy almost unthinkingly
very, very often.
I don't think Sarah was thinking about
this sort of cartographic
map when she said that
but of course, one of
the fantastic projects
that she's been leading
is the human Silas.
So there's outlets again,
we see these analogies coming forward
and it's because there
is a genuine relationship
between that practice that
we're mostly all familiar with,
or maybe with Google maps,
we've all forgotten how to read a map,
but it's the practice that
we're mostly familiar with
of an abstraction of the world.
One of my favorite, I can't remember
where this story comes
from in the first place,
but by the (indistinct) with
the one that I heard it from,
and it's not from him originally was
the notion of the country
that was so good at maps.
He said, when you build them a 150,000,
well, we started going with one to 10,000
that wasn't good enough
and then we decided one to
5,000 that wasn't good enough.
One to 1000, that wasn't good enough.
Eventually we've gone
for a one to one map.
(laughs)
- I think that's Bo Herse's story.
Yeah.
- That's brilliant.
Thank you Priya, for comment.
I was forgetting, I would end up there.
So that's great that we've got the erupts.
And of course that's
nonsensical, that's useless.
The map is an obstruction
and then abstraction that
is used for some purpose.
So this knowledge that we're interested in
is therefore somehow contextual
for what we choose to abstract
is depend on who we are
and what questions we're
interested in asking.
Sarah very brilliantly went
on to sort of talk about,
I thought one of the most
remarkable pieces work
from my point of view was the work on
the way the dimers and
the timers come together.
And this sort of leading
to this predictive
almost like periodic table
of the protein structures.
And I think it's sort of interesting,
again, we see the need
to convert our knowledge
into some sort of system
that we can relate to
the original periodic table.
And of course, and she talked about Mendel
and Daley and genetics
and Mendelian inheritance,
which is actually quite a nice,
simple form of inheritance,
but it's actually quite distant
from the form of inheritance
that we see in much of animal life.
And I think there's an
interesting aspect there
that we are drawn to
obviously explanations
that we can understand.
The bookshelf, the map,
the Mendelian genetics,
the periodic table.
And I think there's a sort
of follow up question,
but is that really the way the world is?
Or is it just the windows that we can see
through when we look at the world,
the things that enable
us to have intuition
about what's happening in the world.
And I don't know the
answer to that question
and perhaps the answer
doesn't really matter
'cause it's sort of more
around for amorphic comment,
but it perhaps does matter very much
in the practice of science
when we're practically,
as Priya said in the introduction,
I'm very keen on what happens
when real-world decision-making comes in
and Sarah again, showed
a wonderful example
of how you can use these technologies
in perhaps diagnosing
COVID and other diseases
and in future other diseases
of the immune system.
If we can use understanding
of the human cell Atlas
to understand how we're being infected,
well, how wonderful would that be?
But this leads me on to
sort of why I think two
really emerging challenges
are in the domain here,
which I think Sarah was
massively dealing with.
And she's the head of her field,
but these are just really challenging
and they keep coming up everywhere.
And there's two paradoxes
that I talk about as the big data paradox.
And then I have a follow on paradox
called a big model paradox.
So Sarah very nicely described
how the data and model interact.
And I tend to think of this as a spiral.
And there's a wonderful
quote from Carl Popper,
which is the answer to the question.
I can't remember whether
he uses hypothesis.
I think he used hypothesis,
which comes first to the hypothesis
or the experiment to which I
would say the model or the data
is the same as the answer to
the question which comes first,
the chicken or the egg, the
answer is that they co-evolve.
So what do we mean by that is early on,
there is a very diffused
kind of experiment,
which unfortunately, some
people call fishing expeditions.
Well, it's a diffuse experiment
that's trying to understand
where should one focus
and that I really dislike
that term fishing expedition.
And then once you've done
that initial experiment
that might inform you,
which is informed by some understanding
the system that helps focus,
that helps refine your
understanding of the system
and you focus down and down.
And I see this as a spiral moving forward,
but what we're trying...
One of the challenges we're experiencing
is we get more and more data in the world,
it strikes me that we seem to understand
less and less about the world
and there are many examples about this.
So for example, we could think
about election predictions.
You'll be getting more
and more information
about who's clicking on what,
what people are saying on Twitter
and yet we seem to be,
if anything, getting worse
at predicting the outcome of elections.
And this is quite a well
understood statistical concept,
how you predict the outcome of elections,
so that's kind of odd.
Or stratified medicine.
So trying to sort of target
drugs at the right population,
as we get more and more
information about patients,
you'd hope that we could get
better and better at that,
and that doesn't seem to be happening.
And I think the reason is the following.
So I observed this some years
ago and spoke about it first
at a talk of data science
Africa as Priya said.
A lot of my interests are inspired
by applications in the African context.
But I couldn't sort of give an answer to,
is what I think is going on.
And it was actually
during the COVID pandemic
that I've come up with
this, my hesitant answer.
And it comes from realization
the same thing happens with modals.
So the big data paradox, I think,
is arising from the follow-up.
It's the sort of example of not being able
to see the wood for the trees or tree.
So what happens is we gain
more and more data about a phenomenal,
and therefore we get
more and more interested
in this data we have and
perhaps more and more focused.
This is sort of data in
attention, blind, that's going on.
We've become very focused
on that data we've required
and we think we've got
a very rich description,
but the description is not representative
of the wider system.
And as a result, we ended up making
very, very biased decisions.
We talked a little bit about bias in data,
and one of the ways that,
and Sarah does a brilliant job
bringing these data sets
together, which is absolutely key,
but not many people
are doing that as well.
You get this very sort of focused dataset
on one small aspect of the entity.
You believe you've understood a great deal
because you've got so much
data, but in practice,
you've actually just understood
a lot about the wrong thing.
So you perhaps you wanted to understand
the small ecosystem
around a tree in a forest,
but what you actually
ended up understanding
is some of the details of
how caterpillar is operating
on one of its leaves,
which is not relevant to
the question of interest.
So you can see how that relates
to this notion of abstraction and the map.
The danger is you go diving in
and what's happening is people are losing
their human intuition about
what goes on in these systems.
They go diving in and collect all the data
in the world without that intuition
and they collect the wrong type of data
because they perform the
wrong type of obstruction.
They get them at one-to-one
scale in the wrong place.
And very similar things
are happening with modeling
and I believe we saw that a lot
in a pandemic modeling
and epidemic modeling,
where you have people
creating richer and richer
descriptions of how diseases
can move through the population.
But if those descriptions themselves
are all based on the idea that the disease
is moving through tart,
rather than aerosol,
most of the aspects of that
description is useless to you.
And actually what you
want is in both cases,
what you want is a model
that's more abstract
that is taking account of less detail,
but is more understandable by everyone
that needs to operate on that model.
And that's not just the
designers of the model
or the collectors of the
data, but the domain experts.
So in COVID, that would be
public health officials.
If you're saying to the
public health people,
you can't understand my model,
then you've got the wrong model.
You need to be able to communicate to them
because they need to be
able to make decisions true.
And I think that that's
something that goes beyond
just the, sort of the
need for us individually
to understand what's going on science,
but it must also be an ability to explain
to other scientists or
the general population
about why these decisions are going on.
So it's not just about
individual human understanding,
it's about societal
understanding of what's going on
and I think that's gonna
become increasingly important.
So I'll just checking my notes
because I'm going to wrap up here,
but I'll see if there's
anything important I've missed.
So, yeah, so it was very good.
So just checking and I'm
at to the point where
it's important that people
can relate to the models
and inferences that we're making
and the big data and big modal paradox
are very much about losing
the ability to do that.
Now, science is super interdisciplinary
and Sarah also mentioned that,
but increasingly our analogies
that we're using in these domains
are dividing us rather than uniting us.
And I think, I really welcomed this series
because I think it's an
opportunity to discuss
how that's coming about,
because we should really
be able to address this
in the methods that we're delivering on.
As a sort of final exam,
I think one of the real challenges we face
is if you go to sort of Priya's comments
at the end of the talk was well,
what's the equivalent of
the conservation of energy?
What's the thing that
we can do and integrate
in these models that we know to be true?
And I think that's one of
the key sort of questions
and challenges we face when we're doing
it's because very often
the cemeteries we understand
that should exist in the natural world
are incredibly difficult
to introduce into these
data-driven models.
But I think the often the
answer is to do exactly
what you saw Sarah doing
throughout her talk, which is yes,
that cemetery is not
embedded in the model,
but you represent in that model.
You represent its prediction in such a way
that if there's an error, you see it.
So if the thing is
behaving in such such way,
so when you produce those maps,
I mean, the mapping that Sarah is using,
there was a sort of little
Twitter thread on it the other day,
but it's kind of notorious for
it can potentially go wrong.
So that part of the art
in that is what brings,
Sarah bringing her knowledge
and certain people that work with Sarah,
bringing their knowledge to understanding
when it's being done right
and when the plot is valid.
And some people don't like
that type of subjectivity,
they don't like that sort
of interaction occurring,
but I actually think it's vital.
And I think we have to embrace that
and better understand that
otherwise we are never going
to do what I sort of said,
we should be addressing at the beginning,
which is the challenge of bringing
to that science, to that
most complex of things,
social science, which
is where we would really
like to be in the end.
And with that, I'll stop, I
think, I overrun the slide.
Apologies for that.
- Thank you so much, Neil, for those
wonderful and rich set of comments.
Sarah, did you want to take a shot?
- Yeah, so I think Neil,
that was absolutely fantastic
and this resonates
perfectly with basically
the way we operate as in
the bioinformatics world,
in terms of, the questions
that you say is the scientist
has to decide which data
to collect and so in that,
from that perspective, actually big data,
the data that's there is a
hypothesis in and of itself
in a certain sense.
It's not a fishing expedition
because you have decided to collect,
to make, to do a certain
kind of measurement
on a certain kind of sample.
And that decision in and of itself,
when you articulated in that way,
it becomes clear that
there's an underlying hypothesis there.
And I think that is a
fantastic way of describing,
let's say genomics,
high throughput biology and so on.
And that it's actually not that different
from your conventional kind
of microscopy experiment,
looking at sort of the cells,
in one sample, in one tissue
or in one cell culture.
So it's simply a larger scale version
of the same thing basically.
And I think that's very illuminating
to kind of frame it in that way.
- Yeah, Sarah, I just wanted
a point of clarification
to ensure that I understood.
And I mean, Neil, aren't
you saying that this process
also embeds subjectivity
and sort of a take, you
have a take when you...
Did you imply that, or
am I misunderstanding?
- I think it does,
but I think you can't separate yourself
from that subjectivity
in a lot of these more complex sciences.
And I would agree with Sarah
in terms of the data collection
itself is somehow expressing a hypothesis.
And one that potentially is very difficult
to write down mathematically.
One of-
- And the same is true of
a traditional genetics,
why did Mendel decide to
score, the color on the peas?
I mean, that's also, there's
a hypothesis in a way,
or the Siemens organizer
experiment that on-
- What you choose to measure.
- The fly, I'm real, the all embryos,
those are kind of
traditional experimental,
but in a way our sort of
era of functional genomics
and big data that that's,
it's often juxtaposed
with that traditional way of proceeding.
But actually I think what
Neil is saying is that
it's not that different and
that completely resonates
with me.
I completely agree with that.
- I think one of the interesting
things that happened,
which I'm sort of fascinated by is,
and I don't know that I'm
not a historian of science,
but it's something that
strikes me as possible
is when statistical
methods were introduced,
they could answer a
certain type of hypothesis,
with statistical confidence.
And I think something incorrect happens
in that there was a section,
and this is certainly not statisticians.
Don't feel this in my experience,
but the certain scientific domains
where people have decided that the only
form of valid science
is to do something that
you can convert into a sort
of randomized experiment
and come up with a P
value at the end of that.
And that's had some awful effects.
E valued hacking is a consequence
of people trying to conform
in domains where they were
unable to do with that.
And it's also had people dismiss
things as non-scientific,
if that's not possible.
Well there's going to be many
situations where we aren't
and Sarah gave excellent
examples around climate,
so let's get a thousand randomized planets
and try this sort of thing to see,
it's just not going to happen.
It doesn't mean it's not scientific.
It just means that the
different approaches are quiet.
And I think when the subject is part
of the scientist expertise,
and you kind of want to introduce that,
I think, I mean, you have
to be aware it's there
and you have to sanity check-
- And I think often that gets
confused with reliability.
I mean, as an impacting reliability,
I totally take your point about this idea
of randomized controlled trials.
I mean, in those kinds
of ways of thinking,
there is an implicit assumption
that you are effectively marginalizing
over all other variables that
you don't even know exist.
You don't even know what they are.
And somehow you're making
an implicit assumption
about the variation in those variables.
Like, there's some,
they're all Garcia in some
way or something, right?
So you are marginalizing,
but I think what was
very powerful about Sarah
as description of the
process that she's following
is that she seems to be
very aware and cognizant
of what is being done at every stage.
Sarah, that was wonderful
and that you're able to-
- Yeah, and I think articulating
the big data approach
with a bioinformatics, as
actually kind of in many ways,
analogous to traditional
molecular biological approaches.
I mean, I think that again, that just,
the way Neil's framed it,
that really strikes a chord with me
because it's true that we
decide what data to collect.
We then decide how to model it,
how to projected from how to ventral space
into motor mental space
and all those decisions.
There's an interpretation element there,
which is just like,
conventional molecular biologist
who would make a small scale measurement,
interpret the data and then decide
what's the next experiment.
And so in the big data, high
throughput genomics error,
that's then, what's the
next set of genomics data
that you collect once
you've made that model.
But in a way, actually the process itself
is the same kind of
iteration of collecting data,
interpreting it, even if
you're using machine learning
and it's more complex statistical models.
And then once you've
done that interpretation,
you're then gonna go on to the
next set of data collection.
And when I say you, it can
be the same research group
or a different part of the community
that's reading that paper,
that's the computational data analysis
and then taking that into
account for the next step.
So it's in a way it's, we
haven't fundamentally changed,
the human or the way we do science
from a human point of view
in the era of big data
thrombogenic, bioinformatics and so on.
- But I think the frame,
but I think you are all,
you've changed the frame though,
because when you look sort of classically
those of us building say
conceptual models in physics.
That is reductionism is
really built in those,
into those models.
So we start out by saying,
let's make a pad down model.
And the subjectivity there,
again, as you mentioned,
comes from the expertise,
when the expert scientists,
she decides what is
redundant, what is extraneous,
what is essential and pass down the model.
And then, so you reduce,
you reduce actively,
and then you slowly add
on bells and whistles
and then go collect the data
that would be appropriate.
That would match the kind
of more complicated mapping
you have to do.
But it seems to me that in bioinformatics,
you are sort of consciously not doing that
and being much more open
in allowing many more possibilities.
And does this lead both of you,
does this lead to more
flexible science in a way?
I mean, would you both think so?
- So, I mean, well, one way
I sort of, I think physics
is this unusual case.
I tend to think of the
spectrum of mechanism
from strongly mechanistic
to weak mechanistic.
So what do I mean by that?
I mean, strongly likely
to say you're more likely
to be seeing a lot of
differential equations
but the civil abstraction in there,
I mean the same planks land
means the world is discreet,
but a lot of this stuff is done
in continuous space, right?
So that's an abstraction.
I mean, it's a really good one.
Or if we look at statistical mechanics
and we look at the behaviors of gaps,
so you get this sort of strong overlap
between what your mechanistic model says
and the way the world behaves.
If you control the world in certain ways,
of course, if you start
getting certain materials,
then they break away from that.
And I think that historically in physics,
there tends to be the focus in that space.
If you go to a sort of
very data-driven model,
I mean, there's a weak
mechanistic assumption
in those models, civically,
either linearity or smoothness.
And very often flexibility is introduced.
I think you can often unpick and say,
as I think you were
implying earlier Priya,
the latent variable is
being introduced to help
if there's something unknown
going on that messes things up.
So there's this spectrum of mechanisms.
I think if you go all the
way back to sort of Gauss
a little plastic,
the people that were doing
this sort of early physics,
and as it turns out early statistics,
it was one world for them.
And what's happened to
these worlds of separated.
Actually, a lot of the
interesting stuff is in between.
And I think that this, but
it's such a difficult question,
how much mechanism and where,
when it comes back to that mapping thing.
So in some sense, what
physics is trying to do
at that very microscopic level
is build a one-to-one map.
So say, no, we've got everything in here
for this controlled circumstances,
but in very complex systems
in the one-to-one map,
wouldn't even be useful,
because the answer that
the scientist wants
to the sort of the questions
that Sarah was asking about COVID
is not because this molecule interacted
with that molecule at some very low level.
It's much more abstract than that.
And I think what fascinates me is the ease
with which human beings do
that type of abstraction
and the extent to which that's missing
from our automated methods.
So I went on too long there,
Sarah, I don't know if that makes sense.
- Yeah, no, that makes total sense.
I mean, there are still
sort of basic obstructions
that underlie our
interpretation of the data
that things like what is a gene,
what is a promoter, which is
the start side of the gene.
So what, what are enhancers?
I mean, there are sort
of fundamental models
that we have in our mind that are implicit
when we analyze the data.
- They're a bit more subject to, I mean,
I know it also happens in physics,
but you always get the sense that,
oh, that's what we
thought are promotables,
but actually this extra
additional thing can happen
that we didn't know about,
things seem to move.
And it's quite hard to describe
in a very pure mathematical
sense how the promoter is in the behavior.
If I go back 15 years so when
I was modeling this stuff,
we used to model, I dunno,
we use like catalyst based models.
I mean, there's what actually happening,
or you see, I think you did
this wonderful thing, Sarah,
you showed first this sort of simulation
of what's going on in the cell
and all of these things moving around
and then you took it down to, okay,
but let's start striking
that into these blockchains.
And then we can see,
what's really interesting about that
is you were taking the
essence of what was important
for the question you were answering.
And you turned that into a set of pictures
that everyone in the
audience could immediately
understand what you were doing,
but of course you just shown the reality
or what we think might be the reality
and that simulation before
where a whole load of
additional stuff is going on.
And I think there's this weird thing
where we keep on getting
drawn into the simple model
that describes the abstraction,
which gets us one aspect,
but we find it very easy to forget.
Well, actually it doesn't look anything
like that in practice.
Whereas, and I know
Priya, so I don't want to,
in physics it kind of feels
like what it does look closer
to the block.
Of course it doesn't look like that,
but you know what I mean.
- Well, I mean, I think in physics,
we have been very obsessed
with sort of the determinism
is really baked into,
what we project as our
understanding of the world
and the mathematical language
that we have developed
to make sense of the world.
And it's, of course it's
surprisingly wildly successful.
So we are really wedded
to it, which is why,
I guess quantum mechanics
is so disorienting
for this as, and everyone alike that,
this whole idea of a
deterministic relationships
and separation between subject object,
observer observed all of these things
that come crashing down
and we have to move to a very
probabilistic description.
But, I think this is probably
one of the sort of blinkers
that physicists really have.
- What the biological
context be more like,
like the kinds of approaches
that engineers use,
for, I don't know.
I mean, I thinking of,
because a lot of the methods that we use
for big data analysis and biology
have actually come from engineering.
So for instance, from image analysis
or from speech recognition,
or from, these kinds of things,
it's not actually the
methods for big data analysis
are less from some sort
of physics physics then.
- Yeah I think you're right.
Yeah I think you're right,
because I think the kinds
of methods you are using
in bioinformatics are
not searching for laws.
You're not looking for laws,
you're not looking for universals.
And I think there's a way in which
sort of physics articulated
through mathematics
is constantly looking
for laws and cemeteries
and sort of universality of descriptions.
You're constantly looking for things
that would, or new categories
that would have some kind
of universal cadence.
Whereas that's why I think,
it's a much more flexible approach.
Yeah possibly, I don't know.
Neil, do you think that's
more of an engineering
take as Sarah suggests?
- I mean, a lot of it
is pattern recognition.
a lot of it boils down to some
form of pattern recognition.
- I guess it depends
which sort of engineering,
I mean, in one sense, when
you first said engineering,
I was thinking so like systems engineering
and there was this sort of great invasion
chemical engineers.
- Yeah.
- And what always strikes
me as is so interesting
about biological systems
that it's as well,
because they evolve, they have all this,
they don't have like,
oh, well just connect that to that.
It's like, whatever the system is like,
oh, well, I could make use of it did,
and redundancy the things that survived,
but the things that have
a lot of redundancy.
And I always find that
so fascinating about
when you work in biological
systems, that side of it,
because it really messes
with your ability,
your intervention, you
thought your intervention
should show something.
But actually what happens is the whole,
some other sub subsystem compensates,
because your idea of what system is,
these evolved systems
didn't go, oh my goodness.
Well, I will have to have that
as a nice separate substance,
but I think then you came in later with,
I think that the stuff, which
I think is quite interesting,
I do think it's-
- I was thinking not-
- All the machine learning
like convolutional,
neural network.
- Yeah, exactly it's
more not the more recent
kind of electrical engineering,
not the dynamical system.
- So I do think, I think
you're onto something there.
And I think it also relates to this point
around abstraction.
I think that the really
big sort of advance
that we've had in machine learning,
which is perhaps it's an advance
because it's driven by data
and compute, I feel is just the ability,
your ability to fit models,
to very large amounts of data
and have this some sort
of automated abstraction
about what's going on.
Be emergent, certainly in,
I'm unconvinced in the biological domain.
And I think that's a really
interesting open question,
but in the domain of vision and speech,
where there are notions
that are very familiar to us
as humans about phones and
phonemes and objects and images,
which we find absolutely
trivial to pick up
as it's very small children.
And, but we were having
a lot of difficulty
teaching machines,
what these abstractions were
and how to interpret them.
And the way we've come
towards being able to do that
is just by showing these
machines enormous amounts of data
and having them figure
it out for themselves.
I mean, horrific amounts of
data, way more than humans need.
And I think that there's
a real interesting thing
that that's kind of what
we would like to be able
to do in biology.
And one of the things like
Sarah and I do one of the things
I'm so excited about the sort
of data Sarah's producing now
is it's data at that
scale where you think,
or possibly we can do that
with biological systems.
But I think it's partially that
it's an unanswered question
about whether we'll be able to say,
I don't know what to think.
- Well, I mean, going back to
the days of genome sequencing,
so the not the kind of
functional genomics,
more sort of downstream
genomics that I work in,
that the see there's many,
many more sequences out there
than there are gene expression patterns
or protein structures
in the public domain,
let's say that the
community has generated.
And those data sets, the methods
like hidden Markov models
were incredibly powerful
at recognizing patterns
of sequence homology and methods in there.
It kind of when I was doing my PhD
and in the mid to late
nineties, early 2000 and so on,
and that was, I mean, to me, that was,
the first kind of where the
light bulb kind of went on
in terms of the power of machine learning,
because they they're so much more powerful
than sort of conventional,
pattern matching methods
at a learning patterns,
physical patterns,
that are also hard for a human to see
necessarily immediately
because you are dealing
with huge data sets,
and then it's really the
machine that models them
so to speak.
And that's also definitely
those astronauts
not astronauts but I mean large
biological data sets exist
and they're growing and they're growing
in different domains of biology now,
I think that's also the
exciting thing is that
we're beyond that pure DNA,
information at the level of
DNA where now not only at RNA,
but also a cellular entities,
which is sort of getting
us closer to biology,
physiology in a way,
and away from the pure kind
of information informational
level of the DNA sequence.
And then it's basically the
challenges and the excitement
is just analyzing that level of data.
That's closer to the biology, if you will,
of a human tissue or an animal,
physiological system
with machine learning.
- I should just have a thought.
So Priya following up.
I was wondering, because I
think it kind of does escape.
Do you think it's escaping
the big data paradox?
I don't know if you
recognize that as a thing,
or if you agree with that,
this notion that if we
collect more and more,
we don't necessarily understand more.
And I don't personally, is it
escaping the big data paradox?
And if so, why?
Because I definitely think
there is definitely domains
where we're not escaping it I think.
- I think part of this
has to do with the fact
that as you mentioned, right the E word
sort of the emergence,
emergence of phenomena,
that we are not able to capture
with any of the other forms,
language, description, models,
and it's the power of emergence
and what we learned from that.
I find that sort of,
I found that very astounding,
especially with, as Sarah mentioned,
but sort of the early work
on sort of the Michigan in
turn teaching neuro networks
of recognize a dog versus a cat
and all of those kinds of
experiments that were happening.
I think where that
eventually led you to is,
analyzing datasets and
suddenly showing you
some sort of what in my
language would be called
a hidden correlation,
but you could not have
it's well hidden.
It's one that you could have
never anticipated at all.
And so perhaps, a connection
in a higher dimensional
domain going back to the language of maps.
But I think that,
the other sort of theme
that I wanted to sort of
get both of your takes on,
and particularly Sarah,
the notion of complexity, right?
And, so what is the future?
I mean, do we just have bigger and bigger
and more complex data and
our tools will keep evolving?
What is your sort of,
what do you see as the prospects
for the kind of biofilm
informatics work that you're doing.
- I was muted,
for the bioinformatics always
goes with the technologies
and the data that's available
and it sort of evolves
as a field in a way in lock step.
I think with that, I mean,
that's a bit of a generalization,
but that's certainly a tight correlation.
And I would say genomics does have a,
there's still a long journey
ahead in terms of not only
the size of the data sets,
but also the domains and areas of biology
that it can be applied to.
And so we talked about
climate change and hurricanes,
and events and so on,
and that we can't perturb them.
And one of the areas where
genomics can contribute
or is contributing now, and sort of not,
I won't use the word encroaching,
but contributing to that area of science
is environmental DNA
and sort of surveillance
of ecologies and
environments on our planet,
sequencing basically not just
animals, but also pathogens,
plants, how they depend on each
other at each other, corps,
have symbiotic relationships.
And so on simply through DNA sequencing
of a lot of ecological samples
and any of that's really,
really relevant now also with pandemic
and know infectious disease.
And in-
- Right, I think you make
a really important point
that it has actually
caused us to shift away
from always thinking about
competition to cooperation.
There've been fundamental
shifts in how we view,
what drives sort of change
evolutionary change and so on
you're right.
- And there's a lots of areas
of healthcare, that will,
we can be on,
genomics can be used as a sort
of early detection method.
You had supplied by
sequencing various samples
from blood, saliva, urine.
So there are lots of areas
where the technologies
can be deployed, in future
and they are evolving towards those areas
and contributing to those areas.
So basically diagnostics
as a routine diagnostic,
you just sequence sample
and sort of in more,
yeah in very practical
ways in everyday life,
as well as in more gain research contexts.
And so in a way, what the
impact that has is that biology
is sort of becoming as a science.
I mean, I am speaking
from my vantage point,
but it's becoming a big
data science basically,
but yet I agree with Neil
is that the measurements
that you make, there's
always a hypothesis.
So it's not like you're
blindly just sequencing
every aerosol droplet in the world.
It's, there's still decisions
that are being made.
And it's a scientific process
with a hypothesis and a model
and an iterative journey
forwards in a spiral like way
using Neil's analogy, I
think that's really accurate.
- Yeah, I think-
- It's sort of,
I think that's where I see the future
of this area of biology.
- But I think what is
particularly liberating
about this direction is that,
we can free ourselves from
sort of this operian view
of it's all about
falsifiability and so on.
So we've broken free of that.
- That's true, yeah.
- And I think that's
actually intellectually
quite liberating
and very productive in terms
of knowledge production.
So the sort of the other sort of question
that I would like to pose to
both of you is how do we know,
how do you know that you are
generating new knowledge?
- It's actually, establishing what's new
when you're analyzing a big data set
with machine learning is actually,
that's actually part of the
scientific challenge or task
or puzzle in and of itself.
And I would, sort of,
I think that's a really
interesting question Priya,
and very partner because
we can gather the data,
we can model it and we're analyzed that
using statistical computational
machine learning methods,
whatever,
but then actually pinpointing what's not,
what's the novel discovery that requires
going back to all the decades
and decades of old literature,
reading all that, digesting all of it.
And then the intellectual
exercise figuring out well,
actually that gene was
known to be in that cell,
but this part actually
that this is a really
golden nugget that's new,
and then we need to
articulate that clearly
because otherwise the community,
kind of understand that
the story or what's.
So you have to,
in a way there's also a very
conventional kind of scientific
exercise there,
that requires the scientists to understand
everything that's gone before
to present it basically.
- So Neil might claim a sort
of provocative claim would be
that what it means to discover
has fundamentally changes
in the data, rich machine
learning, driven era.
Would you agree, Sarah?
- No.
Is it so different?
I mean, it's different in the way you,
the tasks that you perform.
But as Neil said,
actually there's still
an implicit hypothesis
in the data collection,
also in the interpretation,
computational interpretation,
there's subjective elements and hypothesis
that you have in terms
of which models you use.
And then the interpretation
of what's novel
and what's the discovery
is, again, that kind of,
there is that conventional
scholarship that comes into it,
that you need to know
everything that's come before,
and you need to juxtapose the parts
that flips your, that's the
novel contribution and so on.
So is it actually, is it
actually a complete trained,
or is it just a new way
of doing that exercise?
I'm curious to know what you guys think.
- Neil what is your take?
I'm curious to hear your take.
- I think sometimes we
associate with Popper
sort of the falsification
thing as a sort of,
but I think when you read
him, I think he's not,
I think it's the tool of
statistical hypothesis things,
which turns that into a sort
of a very oppressive tool.
I don't think Popper
ever means it like that.
I think it's more of a,
well, I always read it like,
well, my models should kind
of be predictive in some way.
And I think what the challenge
that you're lucinating
in what ways is it predicted?
And I think it relates
to your previous question
about complexity.
And I think also there's
sort of this historical
view of everything through reductionism
that like we should be able to get it down
to this quite simple formula.
And there's lots of reasons
that if we can do it,
that's quite nice.
I mean, I think one answer to like,
how do we know when
we've done something new?
I mean, yes, there's huge
to the scientific world.
But one of the things
that fascinates me is
I read somewhere that like,
until like quite a long way
through the 19th century,
the whole of the natural
sciences tripod in Cambridge
was just teaching, you know?
And now we learn that when we succeed.
And then you've learned,
you've learned something
new if you're compressing
that knowledge, I'm sure they
must've learned other stuff.
And I think part of that
is because of the way
in which we teach it and
the understanding we have
that we develop that it
takes quite a long time.
And that's the real
embedding of knowledge.
Now when it comes to individual things,
I think as Sarah says, it's quite hard.
And I think that we can look
to pop up the gold standard,
that it has to be predictive in some way,
but there is this close
interaction between the human
and the data because of the subjectivity
and what data is being collected
and the subjectivity in
what the variant aspect
of modeling it is.
And that's the thing that
I feel actually potentially
is reduced in what we think
of as the purest sciences,
but we must re-embrace
it, if we're going to do
the social sciences properly,
which I think is a very,
very worthy property.
And they do it very well,
but I have bring the
scientific methodology
to the social sciences.
And it makes me wonder is the answer
it's sort of metal reductionism
that we can be reductionist,
but at a different level,
probably the reductionism
is it doesn't allow
for some of these things
we've been talking about,
because I think that we need
to be able to say no way,
we're putting that back to one side,
we're going to put
Navier Stokes to one side
while we talk about this hurricane.
And I don't quite know how,
I don't know if that makes any sense.
- No, no, I mean, you know this,
so let me try to ask
them this question in.
So Sarah, if it turns out that the notion,
the concept, the conception of a cell
is not the right conception,
how would this big data
actually show you that?
Let's say it's a blob and I'm
just giving some name, right?
Blob doesn't necessarily
mean an aggregation of cells,
a completely different kind of entity.
If it turns out that
one of the ways in which
we have chosen to represent is limited,
because I mean, there's no
question of flaw or whatever,
it's just that it's-
- It's not accurate, yeah.
- So how would it emerge
from this information
rich landscape that you
are exploring and mining,
is there room for something like that,
and is that what you're looking for
when you're looking for a discovery?
I'm trying to sort of-
- No (laughs).
But there are already that
it is a good point because there are cases
where the concept of
the cell isn't actually
no applicable basically.
- Or useful.
- Yeah or useful.
And they include sort of plant structures
that are continuums,
continue of sort of tubes of nuclei
in the Drosophila embryos or
those beautiful stripe patterns
that I showed.
It's actually kind of a bag of nuclei.
That's it's, there are no boundaries,
no membranes or walls
between the individual cells.
And actually the same is true in muscle
where you've got these mild tubes
that are along nuclear iron,
but what it does come down
to and those so the word cell
in or the way we analyze
those kinds of tissues then
is by boiling the cell
down to the nucleus.
And that's the kind of the entity then
where the DNA the
information is transcribed
into the message.
So you're kind of you're then the words,
it's not a solid,
it's that little, little
kind of tiny compartment
that encompasses the
genetic information itself.
And that's how we deal with that.
And-
- I think-
- Wouldn't come out of the data.
I think that would,
that there'd be a limitation,
there there'd be, there
are certain limits.
And I think that's where Neil's
thing about the subjectivity
of the data that you collect is relevant
because you go in,
no, you go in and you know actually
this kind of approach
with this kind of sample,
it's gonna hit its limits
and then you decide,
okay, well, in that case,
we'll use this other approach.
We may, we may not, dis-aggregate
the individual cells.
We may just cut through and
study genomics in a spatial,
in a tissue section, and collect
a different kind of data.
It may still be big data, but
it's a different experiment.
And that's where the,
that's why I like that concept
that actually the scientist
it's not a fishing expedition.
It's not just like a wild
kind of aligned sort of,
completely hypothesis
free collection here.
It's not like it's a bit
different from the sort of,
we're listening for aliens kind of thing
with our radio telescopes, there's more-
- Fishing expedition, but you understand
where the fish should be.
- Right, good idea.
- And where they hang
out where the ponds are.
- You have a good idea.
Where the ponds are,
you're looking for coil,
you know where the ponds are.
- And I think that there's another way
in which maybe the cell,
another way of looking at
your question Priya would be,
I mean, going back to
the math analogy, I mean,
is there ever a way in
which motorways don't exist?
Well, yeah, if you're
walking on the late district,
you're not so worried about
where the motorways are
at that moment.
And I think that that's where
you see the subjectivity
and modeling coming in,
these are sort of concepts.
So we see that in physics as well,
depending on what we're trying to teach,
whether we're trying to teach Newton rule,
whether we're trying to
teach quantum mechanics,
a model and our understanding
of what an atom is,
is changing because you
don't need to look at it
with that final level of granularity.
So I think there's an
argument in terms of the,
perhaps the cell doesn't
exist when we're talking about
different organs in the
body, we're doing organ,
of course it exists,
but it's not relevant in the
way that we're thinking about
the decisions that we're making.
It always only relevant at the edges.
And I think that, there's this wonderful.
Everyone loves the George Box quote,
all models are wrong, but some are useful.
And the way everyone uses that quote
is they then describe
a model that's wrong.
They don't ever describe why it's useful,
but there's a benefit in that.
Better be, the whole paper's great,
but there's another bit in that paper,
he says, it's important to consider
in which way your model is wrong.
There's no use worrying about
mice when there tiger abroad.
So I think that that's the essence
there where the cell does disappear.
Sometimes you don't want to
take into account the cell
because you're either at such a low level
or in the nucleus and you're
worrying about something there,
or you're at such a high level
where it's sort of the level
of fidelity isn't there.
And I think that that's,
this acceptance of
subjectivity in the modeling
just comes through so strongly in biology.
I think it it's there in physics,
but people kind of deny it.
They sort of think of their
model closer to truth.
- Right and I guess in
the ambition in physics
is somewhat different, right?
The ambition was to always get down
to the fundamental building blocks, right?
So, finding out about the quarks,
after having, crack the atom and so on
going all the way down to quarks,
that was the ambition about going
to one of the fundamental building blocks,
even though we know that
in order to understand,
the motion of our moon or
planets in the solar system,
it's utterly irrelevant
how many quarks they are
and what flavors they are, right?
A description of that level of the system
it comes back to the mapping
and your analogy with,
if you're just walking along
footpaths in the lake district,
you don't need to know
where the motorways are.
And, and I think that
maybe the difference,
I'm really trying to understand,
as you can see that I'm trying
to grapple one of the ways,
physics and biology are two different ways
of knowing the world and
what, how are they different?
Are they different?
I think they are different.
And I'm trying to get at
how they are different,
in a very basic, in the most
sort of boiled down way.
So what is really different?
And-
- One of the ways I
sometimes summarize it,
I actually I have this ML
in the physical world thing,
and I use Conway's game of life.
And I sort of say,
because I use quotes from Laplace that say
Laplace determinism, which by the way,
his whole book was about probability
and determinism you
can't get away with it.
So it's so weird that
that's associated with him,
but Laplace determinism,
the Superman quotes,
if an intelligence could
understand where everything is
and all the laws of nature,
we can predict the future.
And then I show 'em Conway's game of life,
which has just three
very, very simple rules
and point out that there's
something called a loafer,
which is an emergent
phenomena in that game
that wasn't discovered until 2013
and the effective God of the game,
the God of the game, Conway
himself didn't know it existed.
So when you go back and you
read these lovely Hawking quotes
for them, we would know the mind of God.
Well you know the mind of God
before all this computation has to follow
from those physical laws
and the sort of three ways
in which uncertainty can creep in,
that is really comes through
in that whole class quote,
one is, cause he says,
we'd know that the situation
of all beings in the universe.
So that's the data,
the natural laws by
which their governance,
that's the model.
And then of course that
intelligence has sufficient,
is a sufficient intelligence
to subject this data
to analysis he says,
or something like this,
and that's the compute.
And one of the things
we biology is so distant
down the computer in terms of
to reconstruct what's happened.
And then when you consider
that evolutionary,
that we're actually seeing
the consequences of billions,
of years of evolution as well
in order to sort of compute this.
I mean, the whole thing with Conway,
and it took us because you have
to do all that computation,
all that exploration of a
very relatively simple thing
to find these emergence moment.
And I just think that
physics is quite close to,
oh, well, what are the
underlying things going on
with these pixels?
Why are they disappearing in game of life?
And biology is sort of saying,
okay, that's nice that that's going on,
but they've shown that the
game of life is a cheering
is turning complete.
So this thing can compute anything.
Why is it doing that?
And when does it do that?
I mean, that to me is that
it's really made a difference.
- Sarah?
- Yeah, so yeah, I try to
always see the similarities
and I'm a 20% in the department of physics
at the university of Cambridge
and the Cavendish lab
in theory of condensed
matter when you have,
the sort of sociological level,
and you've got the theorist,
which is the group that I sit in,
you've got experimentalists.
And in many ways there's
the same kind of dynamics,
that you have in biology.
Having said that, I mean, I'm living,
even in living organisms,
like the E.coli cell that I
was showing in that simulation,
but Neil kind of remember
with all this juggling
protein complexes,
it's got 4,000 genes that
the number of interactions
is kind of common editorially
explosion of that.
And yeah, the complexity of it is just,
it's a different level.
You've got, the circuits,
but a lot of the hugely feedbacks
and robustness redundancy
and all these things
we've discussed kind of
built into the system.
And that is different from,
let's say a crystal and
material, water ice,
these materials they're
been studied for decades in
and modeled and so on and in
theory of condensed matter.
And so that's in fluid dynamics.
And so, I mean, that's really different.
I mean, it's the level of complexity
and the number of components,
the number of interactions and so on.
And I think ultimately
that's what determines.
- Well, and then going
back to some of the protein
folding problem underneath it,
you still got all that
complexity, about why,
what the interactions are
in the molecular bonds
that caused them to folders as well.
- If you take protein folding,
the number of different
atoms in one single 100
and no I supply peptide train
is like it's 2000 or so.
And then they can all be
interacting in different ways
where they try to,
and that's why that
problem still isn't solved.
- But there's still some,
to draw out the similarities
and then I'm gonna talk
about it.
It's not work I do, but being Singh Chang,
who's one of the fellows
in our accelerator program,
she's looking at trying to understand
the behavior of water under
extremely high temperature
and massively high pressure.
And she ends up in this problem with,
trying to do all the
sort of, I don't know,
the Schrodinger equation.
So I don't even remember
all this sort of details
of what you would see sort of doing
and the low level of what's
going on in those bonds.
And she has to simulate it.
And she's still in that
position of not actually
being able to do sufficient compute
to simulate this very simple substance,
as Sarah said, very well studied,
but apparently one of the
things that she said that
just blows my mind,
this is the state that most
water in the universe is in
because it's mostly in the heart
of a very large ice planets
or gas giants,
and we don't even
understand that the phase
that this water is in and
whether it's superconducting
and which I think in
the implication it is,
and it's for the same sort
of reason that you can't do
that simulation at real speed.
And she ends up doing
the same type of thing
that I think is possible
in many of these things is,
is replacing the actual complexity
of the underlying physics,
which with an abstraction that
captures the salient parts
for the simulation you're doing.
And I think that that's a
commonality everywhere that,
I mean, that's why think
of when I think of machine
learning in the physical world,
the ability to find the
salient part of the system
that you're looking at and
abstract it into something
where you can compute that much quicker
so that you can actually
do your simulations
to predict the thing you're interested in.
- Oh, this has been fascinating.
I feel very, I've been very selfish.
I think we should open up to the floor
to see if our audience has any questions.
So I think given that we had
a very tight assembly today
in order to ensure that the
proceedings were smooth,
people can unmute themselves
and ask the question,
ask questions if they like.
- [Ty] Priya, sorry it's Ty.
The only problem is that we
may have problems with that.
- Oh, I see.
Okay, we just go with the chat.
- [Ty] Okay, if you don't mind, sorry.
- Oh, not at all.
That's fine.
Please go ahead and type any
questions that you might have
in the chat as per usual.
And I guess as we wait for people to start
framing the questions,
one aspect of these biological systems
that I find incredibly fascinating,
which again is very similar
to the kinds of systems
that I work on is the temporal scales
over which these systems have functioned,
optimized and operated, right?
Sort of evolutionary timescales.
And I wonder when,
as you are uncovering these
sort of complex relationships,
is there,
is that interest in understanding
sort of the evolutionary
pattern and I mean,
evolution, not in Darwinian,
but the changes over time
like that along the temporal access.
- Yeah, I think that's a really
nice analogy between biology
and astronomy cosmology and so on.
I mean, there's a lot of,
I thought we would talk more actually
about temporal dynamics
and correlation causation,
because that's one way that
you can, you could, you get,
can get a better handle on causation
if there's a temporal sequence.
But and so modeling dynamics
is in biological systems.
And I showed the fly
development is one example.
There's basically a
progression happening there
from the early embryo through development.
That's a really important
element of genomics
and data models and so on and so forth.
It's, I would say the evolutionary,
sort of evolutionary dynamics
is a bit of a different from,
so if you're thinking
about Darwinian evolution,
because of course everything
that we see nowadays
is kind of a snapshot of
the current time when it's,
it's only things like,
digging out really amount
and that kind of thing
that can allow us to actually get an idea
of what happened before the current time
kind of an evolution,
but it's a fact that's also fascinating.
- So there's a related
question that direct
from our evolutionary
biologist as put in the chat.
And his question is,
I wonder whether systems biology
based on single cell transcriptomes
is ready to investigate
the agency of tissues,
signaling centers, electrically
coupled cell aggregations
and mechanical forces and
organismal development?
- So signaling for sure.
I mean, in the sense that,
I showed basically predictions
of cell cell communication
through sort of receptor
ligand complementarity,
and you can then link that downstream
to signatures of expression
downstream of a receptor.
You can link it to-
- With COVID example, right?
So this was-
- No this was the placenta-
- The placenta.
- And how the signaling
takes place between
the how signaling takes
place between the fetal cells
and the maternal immune cells
that prevents rejection.
Basically, so that's there,
there's a huge signaling
circuitry basically
that ensures that that's
very robust and redundant,
actually tons of mechanisms
there to ensure that
tolerance and support of the placenta.
I mean, I didn't go into
all the molecular details.
So that's certainly,
single cell transcriptomes
are very informative there.
I mean, there are also
methods that couple,
the single cell transcriptomes
with electrical signals
to patch seek is a technology
where you couple the patch
clump of a single cell
and measure the electrical
signal, the conductance,
and then link that to the transcriptome
by then sequencing the content
of what's inside the cell that
you suck up in the pipette
and mechanical forces.
I would say there are
various ways of that I think
are very exciting going forward to link
kind of mechanical properties of cells
to the single cell
transcriptomes one is to read out
the molecules that determine
the mechanical stiffness of a cell
or the morphological properties of a cell
and link the images that
you have of a tissue section
in terms of the morphologies,
the shapes of the individual
cells to the transcriptomes
that you sequence from each voxel,
each basically spatial, X, Y coordinate,
basically in the tissue section.
So there are various ways of
getting at these properties
by coupling the single cell
transcriptomes as well,
integrating other kinds of data.
So it's a good, it's a great
question, Richard, thank you.
- Yeah and we have a question from Jenny
who asked that yesterday you
said that the predictive power
is reduced with an
increased amount of data.
Is this really true?
Isn't it rather possible
that the predictive power
of a model is reduced at the scale
that we are currently looking at it,
but may still be strong
on a more detailed level?
- No, so I think that
was a misunderstanding.
So the predictive power of the modeling
has definitely increased with
increasing amount of data.
There's no question about that.
That the plot that I was
showing was data on the X axis
and knowledge and expert
knowledge input on the y-axis.
And basically on the left-hand
side, if you have less data,
you need to input more expert knowledge
to interpret that data,
on the right hand side,
but the high data on the
x-axis tons and tons of data,
the modeling the signal is so strong.
- Yeah, you don't need-
- Exactly, yeah.
That's what it was trying to say.
I hope that makes sense, Jenny
and sorry if it was, yeah, great.
- And I think there's a question
from Fido's and he says,
can you work as described yesterday
in either part one or two,
could that shed light on DNA
double strand breaks and repair?
And his question is from the context of,
harmful DNA damage caused
by ionizing radiation.
And I recently came across
the following article
and summarize double strand breaks
are a type of DNA damage
that can be repaired
by two major cellular pathways
non-homologous end joining
during which the insertions or deletions
may be added at the break site
or homologous recombination
in which the DNA sequence
often remains unchanged.
It's conditions in space,
I guess he's referring
to a lot of the data
we got out of Scott Kelly's time
and the length of the
telemoleth and the changes,
the sort of molecular
level changes from exposure
to radiation he had from his long social
at the international space station, right?
And so he's asking whether
the CRISPR-Cas9 gene
editing system offers a model for the safe
and targeted generation
of double stranded breaks
and eukaryotes,
and would a CRISPR based
assay for DNA break induction.
And yeah, so he wants to know
if CRISPR-Cas9 would deliver.
- So I would sort of say that
the transcriptomic readout
of a cell can tell you about mutations
only in the regions that
are transcribed, obviously.
And you also need to have a reference
to the non-mutated reference basically.
So that can be another cell,
or it can be a reference DNA sequence.
And in that way, by
aligning comparing data,
you can make inferences about mutations.
- But can you fix them?
- And,
well, you can, I guess the way,
so cell based therapies
for instance rare diseases for cancers,
or for where genetic disorders,
they are kind of fixing
mutations by delivering cells.
Well, you could either use CRISPR yes
to fix the mutation, deliver
it, deliver the enzyme
with a guide on it, to the cell,
or you could actually deliver
kind of substitute cells
that are healthy basically.
- I don't think I'm
missing any questions yet.
Please feel free to
have a few more minutes
before we wrap up.
'Cause we could keep going.
This has been such a wonderful session,
but it's getting late for Sarah and Neil.
And are there any further questions Ty?
Did I miss anything?
- [Ty] I didn't see any, no.
- Great, so I guess before we wrap up,
I would like both of
you to tell us briefly,
what are the next exciting steps
in both of your research directions?
Very, very curious to know what it is
that you're really
thinking about right now.
And what's very exciting?
- Well, I think from me, basically the map
of all the tissues in
the human body and this,
I think really interesting
from our discussion is also,
what's the right level of
mapping the human body.
We obviously have a pretty
good knowledge of our organs,
but a much less accurate knowledge
of the cells in our body.
And actually, what are
the ways in which that
very highly resolved single cell knowledge
or for molecular breadth,
what are the ways in
which that is informative
and what are the ways in which that's not?
So the human cell contract,
where are the areas where
it can really impact
on human health on understanding
or where the ways that
actually a higher level map
or more corresponding map
or a more detailed map,
going down to the atomic level
are actually better
descriptions of our body.
I mean, I think those are
really interesting questions
for me, the applying the
power of these highly resolved
and spatially resolved
genomics technologies
to the body, the immune system,
the components of the
immune system in our body
is gonna be the direction of
travel for the coming years
and expanding that to
the human genetic scale
and understanding, how
we vary from each other
across human beings across the globe.
We're obviously different from each other,
in subtle ways in this group.
And there's more diversity
on earth as a whole.
And can we understand that at the cellular
and molecular level, using these highly
resolved technologies and
gathering even more big data
on making a cell atlases
of lots and lots of tissues
of hundreds and thousands of people
and interpreting them with
Neil's got and process
latent variable models or
other machine learning methods,
I think is a really exciting way forward
in this whole paradigm
that we've discussed
where we're using genomics technologies
that generate big data sets
and then use statistical
computational machine learning
methods to interpret
them and iterate on that.
And this it let's call it
a new paradigm of science,
whether it's really completely new or not.
I think we've discussed that hear
and it's been really wonderful
and I'm funded to try to both.
- And Neil, what about you?
What is the exciting?
- The pleasures is I get to listen to like
this sort of thing Sarah
is gonna do and think,
oh, maybe I can help (chuckles).
And that is a really great pleasure
and something I really enjoy.
And I think comes in terms of
immediately achievable aims.
There's a lot of projects.
It's one of the great things
in machine learning like that.
I mean, Sarah's probably
the most interesting.
But I think there's another,
another thing I'm interested in
and don't really have a
handle on how to attack
and maybe there's like
a 10 to 15 year thing,
but I think that there's
sort of a smooth path.
I think it's a serious problem is that
as we've talked a lot
about how these methods
are used in computational biology,
but of course these
methods have been deployed
across society.
And when you think about them
in this sort of social context, I mean,
naive use of these methods has
led to all sorts of problems,
filter bubbles in manipulable elections
and so on and so forth.
And this leads to a
thought for me, that is,
we cannot be in a world where
we are being operated on
by the whim of these techniques.
And the only way we can turn that around
is by gaining more control over
what these things are doing.
And what does that mean
for sort of normal people?
What does that mean to produce techniques
that normal people failing control of
that are dictating things
about how their lives are carrying out?
And I think that's a
very difficult question
and there's sort of
easy engineering answers
and sort of very difficult to have answers
about what that could look like.
So that's something I'm
very, very interested in,
but it's kind of,
it's actually extremely hard
to publish stuff in this area,
and it's extremely hard
to get everything in place
that you need to do work at this area.
So that's why it's great,
in the meantime, I also get
to work with Sarah's team
or my team works with Sarah's
team and some of these things
that we could perhaps
answer more immediately.
- Great, thank you.
Thank you so much both of you
for absolutely fascinating
conversation today
and Sarah, once again,
thanks for the brilliant talk yesterday
and you're a very patient
composer through the disruptions
as well.
So I just want to say
thanks to the audience.
Oh, I think there's a question
that has just popped up.
Let me, oh, this is Tyler, Tyler who says,
Jose Ortega Gasset argues
fascinatingly that the phrase
missing the forest for the trees
is fundamentally incoherent
forests offers don't
actually exist out there
in the normal world, but instead represent
the sensation of being confronted,
the inscrutable vastness
of a Grove of trees
to understand what a
forest, is in other words,
is precisely to miss the
forest for the trees.
Is that a sense in which
Neil's big data paradox
is a feature and not a fault?
- I think it's a great question.
- It's a great question.
- And it goes right to the
heart of what we're saying.
Think that the problem is we
don't have control over that.
So I don't think I would disagree
that it's fundamentally coherent.
And I think on missing it's coherent
is misunderstanding this
point about abstraction.
What is important if I'm
the forestry commission
working out how much, what
I'm going to grow next year,
it's by number and stale of forests,
perhaps less the individual trees.
It depends what I'm doing.
And this is kind of what I
mean about meta reductionism.
That it's subjective the answer to that,
the problem we face with
the big data paradox.
And it is something that
technically I'm interested
in how you solve it and
actually got some prisons,
latent variable loans to offer a solution.
But this was a thing that
Sarah is using in her team
is that you miss this ability to control
whether you're looking
at the forest or the tree
you like classical statistics
gives us the forest.
We understand very well how it
gives us the forest and why.
And then we think we're gonna get
a little section of the forest,
but we go immediately all
the way down to a leaf
and some insect on it.
We don't manage to get to
the sort of the structure
we're interested in because
we don't have the sort of dial
to move around these things.
So I don't think it's
incoherent in a statement,
but I do think what
you want is the ability
to move smoothly across the spectrum.
And you kind of want
that across all sciences
and it relates very closely to this.
I think that those spectra is
kind of like between physics
and biology and things like that.
- And I think we, let's close with that.
Very, very nice question.
And I think,
I'm just very tempted to make
one small comment is that,
often they have been sort of,
the sociologists of science
have often critiqued
narratives of science
that scientists offer
in which they separate out the context.
And the context doesn't really matter
because of this sort of,
slim notion and
understanding of objectivity.
And I think that the
context really matters.
And I think both Neil
and Sarah are telling us
that the kinds of questions you ask
and what questions you ask
really depends on the context
and what is it that
informs the question is
almost as important as the
question itself, right?
So thanks everyone for
this wonderful session.
And I thank you both and see you all
at the next next month colloquium, bye.
Take care and-
- Bye Priya.
Thank you Neil.